die habe ich noch die weiche Butter die
kann ich jetzt schön cremig aufschlagen
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es eine süße Spezialität
heute gibt es nämlich eine Snickers
Rolle dafür ist sogar aus dem Keller
hervorgekommen
und wie sieht die Snickers Rolle aus ja
Mama
ja und zwar ist es eine Biskuitrolle die
schmecken soll wie Snickers das heißt
ich habe da eine Biskuitteig der ist mit
Schokolade ich habe eine Karamellcreme
Erdnüsse mit dabei und das ganze
ummantelt mit Schokolade und ich glaube
schon dass es so ähnlich schmecken wird
wie Snickers Eis falls ihr das kennt und
soll eben so ähnlich sein wie das
Sneakers Regel schmeckt das Snickers
okay dann würde ich euch jetzt erstmal
den Biskuit zeigen denn damit jetzt
direkt los
für den Biskuit verwende ich 4 Eier 100
Gramm Zucker etwas Vanilleextrakt und
Salz 100 g Mehl und 30 Gramm Kakao wie
bei einem Biskuit üblich sind die Eier
schon Zimmer warm dann lassen sie sich
nämlich aufschlagen
und jetzt gebt ihr den Zucker
Vanilleextrakt und Salz dazu und
verrührt die Masse richtig schön lange
etwas
Entschuldigung wenn das Bild wackelt
den Ofen habe ich jetzt auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 210 Grad ober-/unterhitze
und das wird jetzt einfach verrührt
[Musik]
ich finde ja dass so eine Eier
Zuckermasse für ein Biskuit das eins der
Most satisfying Dinge in der Küche ich
finde die sieht einfach immer schön aus
weil es eben so luftig ist einfach schön
luftig
so den Schneebesen brauche ich jetzt
nicht mehr
der darf in die Spülmaschine wenn aus
Edelstahl besteht und jetzt nehmt ihr
Kakao und Mehl und sieht das Ganze dazu
das backmehl muss eigentlich nicht
gesiebt werden aber ihr seht beim Kakao
schon der ist richtig schön klumpig also
richtig nicht schön klumpig und deswegen
muss der auf jeden Fall gesiebt werden
[Musik]
und jetzt vorsichtig unterheben
dann habe ich jetzt hier diese super
luftige Biskuitmasse den Ofen habe ich
auch schon vorgeheizt auf 210°c
[Musik]
denn da muss schnell und kurz gebacken
werden damit er nicht austrocknet und
später beim Aufrollen nicht dreist und
ich muss sagen früher habe ich ja
Biskuit auch auf ganz normalen
herkömmlichen Blechen gebacken die ist
eben im Backofen gibt aber seit ich mit
Backrahmen Backe sind die biskuitplatten
halt immer schön weil da die Luft schön
durchkommt durch dieses Lochblech und
die Hitze gut zirkuliert und dann könnt
ihr wirklich acht bis neun Minuten
backen die Biskuitplatte rausnehmen und
sie ist einfach perfekt und ich habe da
ja diese schönen Ecken und deswegen wird
die halt immer schön Marken Verschnitt
also wenn ich überlegt dass ich das
früher auch so im maiblchen gemacht habe
so ist schon immer schöner man hat immer
so diese schöne gerade Fläche die immer
perfekt backt
dann backe ich den jetzt nämlich und
werde in der Zwischenzeit Zutaten
richten für die Creme denn das ganze
wieder eine Snickers Rolle und das soll
natürlich auch das Snickers Geschmack
rein das heißt Erdnuss und Karamell muss
mit rein
[Musik]
perfekt
8 Minuten
[Musik]
sind perfekt
die Biskuitplatte ist gebacken ich habe
sie nach dem Backen direkt von der
Backform ausgelöst damit sie eben nicht
trocknet dann auf ein sauberes
Geschirrtuch gestürzt und aufgerollt so
kann sie nämlich hervorragend Abkühlen
jetzt kommt die Füllung dran und für die
Füllung habe ich mir gedacht das muss
auf jeden Fall was mit Karamell sein auf
jeden Fall Erdnüsse damit ich diesen
Snickers Geschmack rein bekomme und weil
wir alle Buttercreme so lieben gibt es
eine Karamell Buttercreme und dann noch
eine Karamellfüllung ich verwende für
die karamellbuttercreme 100 g solltet
Caramel Futures 400 Gramm Milch 50 Gramm
Stärke 200 g Butter die ist bereits
weich und für die Füllung habe ich hier
100 Gramm Karamellcreme die
selbstgemacht und dann braucht ihr noch
100 Gramm Erdnüsse die sind bereits
gesalzen hier bei dieser Karamellcreme
ist es so da gibt es ein Rezept auf
meinem Kanal also Karamellsoße könnt ihr
gerne herstellen und so wie die ist
könnt ihr sie wirklich im Kühlschrank
fast ewig Lagern ich habe die auch
bestimmt schon
seit Anfang des Jahres in meinem
Kühlschrank und die wird da auch nicht
schlecht ihr könnt aber auch natürlich
auf eine fertige Creme zurückgreifen
okay hier brauche ich jetzt auch keinen
Zucker weil ich eben die Fortis verwende
jetzt gebe ich einfach mal einen Teil
der Milch in den Topf
so ein bisschen was lasse ich übrig für
die Stärke
und hier kommen jetzt die Fortis rein
die sind schön süß schmecken nach
Karamell und die dürfen sich jetzt in
der Milch auflösen das heißt die Milch
jetzt aufkochen lassen
[Musik]
und die restliche Milch einfach mit der
Stärke verrühren
damit sie keine Klümpchen bildet
[Musik]
und jetzt schön rühren damit dann nichts
anbrennt und anklebt und dann lösen sich
die
karamellwürfel schön in der Milch auf
wenn die Milch dann kocht ziehe ich sie
ganz kurz vom Herd herunter
die Bonbons haben sich jetzt schön
aufgelöst und jetzt rühre ich die
stärkemasse ein
[Musik]
so verhindere ich nämlich dass es klumpt
während ich das jetzt hier eine Röhre
und dann brennt euch auch wirklich
nichts an
ihr seht es die Stärke bindet auch
sofort aber das ganze muss jetzt
trotzdem noch mal auf den Herd und für
etwa eine Minute gerührt werden damit
eben die Stärke gut binden kann und der
Pudding fest wird
[Musik]
dann darf die Karamellcreme abkühlen
Wortfindungsstörungen die Karamellcreme
darf jetzt Abkühlen dafür fühle ich es
jetzt um in einen Teller und ich nehme
da tatsächlich gerne im Mai Teller dazu
weil die die Hitze sofort annehmen und
eben abgeben und dann kühlt es extrem
schnell
aber ihr könnt auch gerne einen ganz
normalen tiefen Teller nehmen oder hat
einen flachen Teller
und jetzt verteilen so als dicken
Klumpen da kühlt es eben nicht so
schnell ab und wenn man es verteilt dann
eben umso besser jetzt direkt an der
Oberfläche abdecken damit sich keine
Haut bildet ich muss sagen dadurch dass
ich jetzt echt die Silikonprodukte auch
als Deckel benutzt ich schaffe es
tatsächlich fast komplett auf
Frischhaltefolie und Alufolie zu
verzichten also ich würde sagen ich habe
Frischhaltefolie und Alufolie bestimmt
ewig nicht mehr benutzt
ja finde ich immer wichtig kein Müll und
kein Abfall machen so weit es geht es
geht nicht immer aber hier geht es zum
Beispiel
perfekt dann kann das hier abkühlen
und
dann geht es gleich mit der Buttercreme
weiter
die könnte auch gerne herstellen wenn
das hier backt aber das backt ihr so
schnell und dann will ich euch nicht zu
viele Dinge auf einmal zeigen deswegen
macht es ruhig nacheinander dann artet
es nicht im Stress aus und dann vergisst
man nichts auf dem Herd
der Pudding ist abgekühlt hier habe ich
noch die weiche Butter die kann ich
jetzt schön cremig aufschlagen
zumindest die Hälfte davon die Hälfte
davon creme ich auf dem schlagen die
andere Hälfte bitte auf eure
Arbeitsplatte auf der sauberen
Arbeitsplatte denn sie wird 100 mal
gewünscht am Tag hier
verteilen dann wieder in die Schüssel
rein kratzen
[Musik]
so
und jetzt wirklich schön weiß cremig
aufschlagen so etwa fünf bis sechs
Minuten und dann kann ich hier nämlich
schon mal den Pudding schön verrühren
[Musik]
wenn die Butter dann so aussieht also
schön weiß cremig könnt ihr die
abgekühlte durchgerührte Puddingcreme
hier reinrühren schön esslöffelweise
dann könnt ihr jetzt hier die
Biskuitrolle auspacken
schön sieht sie aus da kommt jetzt die
Buttercreme rein schön rein
und dann könnt ihr die gut verteilen
hier unten immer so ein bisschen Rand
lassen
[Musik]
und dann nehmt ihr euch die
selbstgemachte Karamellcreme ihr könnt
wie gesagt auch eine fertige nehmen und
die wird jetzt hier drauf gestrichen
die könnte jetzt schön hier drüber
verteilen
[Musik]
jetzt noch die gesalzenen Erdnüsse
drüber
[Musik]
und hier ist auch wirklich wichtig dass
die gesalzen sind denn ansonsten
schmeckt die Rolle später zu süß also da
hat man wirklich schön diesen salzig
süßen Ausgleich und jetzt vorsichtig
aufrollen die wird auch schon ziemlich
groß
[Musik]
dann schlagt ihr am besten das Tuch so
drüber
und dann kommt ihr in den Kühlschrank
damit die Buttercreme schön fest wird
und die Rolle eben schön zusammenhält
bisher sieht es ganz gut aus
also da die Anna gerade noch arbeiten
kümmert du dich mal um die Schokolade
und ich finde das ganze die
snickersrolle ist nämlich noch im
Kühlschrank jetzt haben wir hier die
Zutaten die habe ich euch ja schon eben
gezeigt aber ich zeige es euch noch mal
mit der Kamera warte kurz
und zwar brauchen wir jetzt 200 Gramm
Zartbitterschokolade 200 g
Vollmilchschokolade
40 Gramm Kokosöl und Erdnüsse und die
Jutta hat jetzt hier schon mit der
impfmethode die Schokolade vorbereitet
also sind jetzt hier für mich gerührt
zwei Drittel der Kuvertüre haben wir
jetzt über dem warmen Wasserbad
geschmolzen ist hier schon geschmolzen
okay warte mal einmal hier schön
sehr gut
jetzt impft die Jutta mit dem restlichen
Drittel der Schokolade die flüssige
Schokolade und dann kommt gleich noch
Kokosfett dazu
[Musik]
Anna hast du am Wald
[Gelächter]
so magst du wieder übernehmen
da ist er wieder eure regieführende
moderierende Kamerafrau Sally jetzt
wieder in der Küche das was Sie besser
kann
und der Profi wieder hinter der Kamera
das ist super gemacht
ja also wir haben schon gesagt hier
Jutta Gerdes hat schon Spaß gemacht
sein was zu sagen das Problem war ich
wollte ja Jutta Rede lassen aber ich
hatte das Mikrofon
Jutta ich wollte dich moderieren lassen
aber ich habe vergessen Dich zu
verkabeln also jetzt haben wir hier die
temperierte Kuvertüre ich habe ja auch
noch ein paar Erdnüsse und zwar habe ich
die schon gehabt und die kommen jetzt
hier direkt mit rein
denn die snickersrolle wird mit
Erdnüssen
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt die Biskuitrolle aus ich
habe die vorher noch mal so ein bisschen
zusammengedrückt das geht ganz gut
sobald die Buttercreme fest ist und
jetzt schneide ich nach vorne und hinten
das Ende weg damit sie schön gerade ist
das darf man halt dann gleich vernaschen
[Musik]
und dann platziere ich sie jetzt hier
drauf
einfach ein abkühlgitter und eine Form
drunter die die Schokolade aufhängt
so schön in Form bringen
und der Rest muss jetzt ein bisschen
schnell gehen also ihr könnt jetzt gerne
auch mehr Kuvertüre schmelzen aber dann
habt ihr natürlich auch mehr was ihr
später wieder verwerten müsst das heißt
ich gieße jetzt hier die Kuvertüre
drüber versucht sie direkt mit einer
Teigkarte immer wieder aufzufangen so
dass die komplette Rolle damit überdeckt
ist
[Musik]
dann nehme ich das ganze hier direkt
runter das ist da nicht festklebt
auf eine Backfolie und darauf
lasse ich die Rolle jetzt Erkalten im
Kühlschrank natürlich
sieht gut aus ich freue mich richtig
die ist noch schöner geworden als ich zu
mir vorgestellt habe
und mit dem Rest hier könnt ihr gerne
Rocky roads zubereiten ihr habt jetzt
schon flüssige Schokolade Erdnüsse packt
dann noch ein bisschen Salzbrezeln rein
getrocknete Früchte alles was ihr mögt
ein Rezept dazu findet ihr auch schon
auf meinem Kanal und dann habt ihr
direkt noch eine andere Leckerei
und jetzt probieren
ja keine zusammenschneiden wir schneiden
zusammen an okay zuerst Ella schauen wir
mal an
wir schneiden wir schneiden hier an und
wir machen das Messer vorher ein
bisschen warm okay wieso warm damit die
Schokolade nicht so auseinanderbricht
man kann es auch einfach in heißes
Wasser tauchen oder wenn ihr einen
Heißluftfön habt könnt ihr natürlich
diesen testamen heißen aber Mama
dann geht dann schnell Stoff das Messer
so heiß wird es nicht
[Applaus]
darf die Schokolade nicht
zusammenbrechen doch darfst du schon
aber ich glaube fürs Foto gleich wird es
auch schöner zusammenschneiden
okay mama warum ist es ein japanisches
Messer
wow das geht jetzt durch wie durch
Butter
aber es Schmelz
nehmen wir noch eine Gabel 2 hier
wow
sieht so gut aus okay hier also optisch
welche Note würdest du mir geben so für
das Aussehen der Rolle
3000 also die Noten Schulnoten sind ja
von 1 bis 6 eins ist die beste und sechs
ist die schlechteste Note welche Note
bekomme ich fürs Aussehen für die
Snickers Rolle 1 plus plus plus plus
plus plus
danke und jetzt können wir mal probieren
da weiß jemand was gut ist geht gleich
an den karamellkern
oh mein Gott
die Karamellcreme ist immer so schön
salzig
und hier ist ja auch bisschen salzig
gell
weil ich auch salzkaramell und salzige
Erbsen
ja
lecker schmecker
sehr gut also den Geschmackstest hat die
Rolle bestanden
Ella hat uns ein 1+++ gegeben fürs
aussehen und welche Note bekommen wir
für den Geschmack
sehr schön ihr könnt ja gerne mal in die
Kommentare schreiben ob ihr auch
Snickers Fan seid also Erdnuss und
Karamell oder ob es ein anderes
Süßigkeit gibt für die euer Herz höher
schlägt ich bin mal gespannt ich bin ja
auch so ein Raffaello Fan als mit Kokos
zum Beispiel was ich tatsächlich nie so
richtig mochte vielleicht magst Du immer
von euch ist so Milky Way weil das für
mich so so ein Riegel warte einfach
immer nur so weich war und Schokolade
außen rum also so ohne Geschmack aber
Erdnuss bin ich ein großer Fan
Schokolade bin ich auch ein großer Fan
ich habe jetzt hier Zartbitter und
Vollmilch gemischt damit es einfach
nicht so süß ist wenn man nur Vollmilch
nimmt aber wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr
auch natürlich gerne nur
Vollmilchschokolade nehmen das ist euch
überlassen das Rezept findet ihr wie
immer auf sallys-blog.de und in meiner
App ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim
Nachmachen und schreibt mir gerne welche
Süßigkeit ist man nachmachen soll oder
welche Süßigkeit euch eben am besten
schmeckt bis dann tschüss
Mama ja Süßigkeit
wie wäre es mit
Milch
dieser weiße Riegel mit Kokos besser
regeln mit Kokos
ich kenne keinen weißen Ring ach doch
nee ich gehe noch einen dunklen Regeln
mit Kokos ich kenne nur Bounty
Rolle
gute Idee Ella danke eine baut die Torte
gibt's schon auf meinem Kanal aber eine
bountyrolle
so also tschüss
dann essen wir es langsam okay Mama
wann hast du gemacht die bountierrolle
vor zwei Jahren
war ich auch schon auf der Welt ich
glaube ja
[Musik]